hi there
steve kaufman
today i'm going to talk about drinking
sake
and language learning
i posted on my blog the linguist on
language
and i talked about how uh in japan very
often when you go to uh
a drinking establishment like an izakaya
and they pour you sake they'll often put
the little glass
the little glass drinking glass inside a
wooden museu which is like a square
cup and when they pour the sake it'll
overflow the little glass and just gets
it collects inside the masu but
basically you're overflowing it and then
you drink from this glass and
you don't really worry about how you end
up collecting all the rest of the sake
because sure enough pretty soon the
waitress or your friend is going to pour
you some more and it'll overflow the
glass and it's a great feeling of
abundance you know we can we got so much
we can waste we're
about you know we're just
overflowing in in the sake and that's
exactly the way i see learning languages
it's a matter of of
letting the words kind of overflow
and and you pick up some and others kind
of
flow past you but they don't really
because they're still there somewhere
you pour again and few more stick and so
forth
and where you you come into contact with
these words of course is in your in your
listening and reading so
you know i posted on this and i had a
number of comments from people some
people liked the image
and felt it reflected that the way they
learned
of course you have the other people who
sort of say well you know if that's the
case why bother saving words you know we
say words that link so why bother saving
them if you're not going to remember
them of course you're not going to
remember them you're going to forget
most of them the first time the second
time the third time but you'll hit them
again and again that's kind of the image
and some people they try to study these
lists of words and they think that if
they study them long enough and if they
have them in their
you know anki system and the ones that
they didn't get will come back again
that they're gonna learn them i actually
don't believe that i think some of the
words you're gonna learn right away and
some of them you're just not gonna learn
them you know or for a long long time
and why that is i don't know and so why
keep torturing yourself with words that
are just hard to learn eventually you'll
come across them in enough context that
that they're going to stick
uh
and so i'm always i guess in these
videos contrasting the sort of just let
it come at you you'll figure it out
approach which is mine
within reason and the other you know i
gotta learn this and i'm gonna learn
this rule i'm gonna learn these words
and i'm gonna get my pronunciation right
i'm gonna nail it all down and have a
solid foundation on which to build the
anti-moon people have this thing you
know pronounce it right from the
beginning or you'll be reinforcing your
mistakes
you know get it right right away and i
just i don't understand that no other
people you gotta be very careful in this
whole language learning thing that you
know i learn certain ways other people
are other ways i can't say that their
way is wrong
but it's not
what works for me
and and i think people have to accept
that if i say it works for me that it
does work for me
and so you'll get people like i again i
had
done
a video in youtube in japanese
and someone said to me how do you deal
with the participles in japanese
and i said i haven't a clue what a
participle is in japanese and i'm sure
most japanese people don't know what a
participle is i manage fine in japanese
so this person comes and came back and
said well if you don't learn the grammar
obviously you can't possibly speak
correctly or something
and someone actually came back and said
well if you don't study the participles
then you must be illiterate in japanese
like why this intolerance
no actually i'm not illiterate in
japanese i read newspapers i read novels
i i write in japanese using uh
you know word processor mind you
and i don't know what a participle is
and it really doesn't matter
it again staying with japanese you know
there are these uh
little expressions in japanese like
um
so
can you teach that no these are things
you just have to kind of get used to
so many things in the language are there
to be discovered and if you discover
them and they eventually stick and
become habits then that's fine
i was up in peace river alberta
and there's a lady there who runs a
chinese restaurant peace river a
thousand people up in northern alberta
and the peace river country
her family has been there for
i don't know 10 15 years the only
chinese family in the community
and she has her little cantonese accent
but
her expressions her use of the word and
she arrived there from china 10 or 14
years ago she's probably late 30s early
40s
and she talks to people on the phone who
are phoning to make arrangements for
whatever they're going to do and her
three kids are off at school and they
come
come in and then she has some teenagers
in the town working and i watch her
communicate she didn't learn that in a
book
she didn't learn about participles but
she's very natural very natural in her
use
of the language and if someone has
suggested her you know get it a hundred
percent right at the beginning if you
don't pronounce it correctly yell for
you forever whatever i mean she was just
given up and gone home so
uh all this to say
once again i mean i'm a bit of a broken
record but people come at me and say
well you must be illiterate
no
there is an approach to language
learning which says just let it all flow
over you read stuff you like
uh
you know there's another one i was
cleaning up my office today
and my swedish you know essentially i'd
forgotten it
although i was born there then i went
there for summer
but i couldn't really use it for
business and i can remember when i
started doing business in sweden i
bought all kinds of books about the wood
business and about forestry and about
the environment and i and so and i was
cleaning up my office and i came across
all these old books that i had bought in
swedish and i remembered of course i
read all these books because i was
interested so reading is is big but so
is listening and just let the words wash
over you and you'll be surprised at how
much you can learn that way without
having to worry about nailing them down
making sure you learned all the words on
your list
making sure you got it right worrying
about how it's pronounced worrying about
what a participle is
and all these funny terms that they come
up with to explain
grammar for japanese and chinese so just
a brief little ramble there and boy you
know that really makes me thirsty i
would really it would be you know
great now to sit down for uh
some sashimi
or you know uni sushi
and have some sake poured in a cup too
until it overflows
but unfortunately i won't have that to
see me thank you for listening bye for
now